We've talked about the three factors of authentication, authentication by knowledge, ownership,
and
We've talked about the three factors of authentication, authentication by knowledge, ownership, and characteristic.
We can use these different factors, alone or in combination, to achieve what is often
referred to as single or multifactor authentication.
Let's start with single factor authentication.
What does that mean?
Well, at the most basic level,
single factor authentication simply means
that we use one of those three factors of authentication.
So it's simply authentication by knowledge
or authentication by ownership
or authentication by characteristic by themselves.
So if I were to ask you this question,
a user logs into a system using an RSA ID token.
What is that?
Is that multifactor or is that single factor?
And the answer of course is that it's
single factor authentication
because the only factor of authentication
they used by just using an RSA ID key
is authentication by ownership.
Now, what about multifactor authentication?
You've undoubtedly heard this term.
It gets thrown around all of the place.
What is the true and perfect definition
of multifactor authentication?
The perfect definition is that multifactor authentication
is two or more different factors of authentication.
And so a key to my bank is a perfect example of this.
Just recently, they rolled out
this whole multifactor authentication initiative
and they were very proud of themselves
that they now had MFA multifactor authentication.
And what you had to do, what you have to do now,
to log in with MFA is you have to provide first your password
and then answer a security question.
And is that multifactor authentication?
Well, it's authentication by knowledge
and then authentication by knowledge.
Two factors, but they're the same factors.
So that is not truly multifactor authentication.
So that's the difference between single factor
and multifactor authentication.
So that means that you're not 100% integrated.
That's what you needed.